let's go for it today I'm gonna do the
idiot test and to punish myself and
forget it wrong I will put tape on my
face
simply click the square to begin boom
press the big red button to continue
this test boom nailed it
press the rectangle to continue boom
Butterbean press the red button twice
then the green button once alright one
two that configure Christ a blue times
then okay one two three one two three
four boom bada bing bada BAM I'm a
genius
way to go you passed the first level you
can now consider yourself as a
borderline Indian to continue press the
picture of a cat when those are two cats
but that's a cat nailed it
press the yellow button once then place
the boot blue button and then the yellow
again I see
ah what you kidding me what
alright [ __ ] it that's [ __ ] I did it
right how do I look yellow blue yellow
[ __ ] you what is this are what is this
what did the formation of bonds look
like a happy face the letter R a duck
what's the formation the letter R say
I'm not an idiot
press the lightest blue square that one
oh god no this way oh god no I am an
idiot I think that looks prettier I
tracked him hey girl oh yeah oh okay
the light is Blue Square you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's this one Wow press the square twice
uh-huh AHA don't press the green button
[ __ ] you good job I am kind of smart
what god damn a check on better tape I
don't want to look though you want to
make out there we go
do not press the blue one [ __ ] you press
the yellow square
ah there blue three green three yellow
to red okay I got it
oh you [ __ ] Ibaka do it in the order
how was I supposed to know
hi hey Carl
how you doing have you ever dated a
YouTube celebrity before
oh [ __ ] you are you [ __ ] kidding me I
understand if Halle I'm smart you know
no way oh [ __ ] see I'm not doing it'll
hurt uh sorry god I look so good told my
ladies out there call me
ah all right this this is a stupid idea
like oh my [ __ ] video ah ah be a
little full results
alright well I think we learned
something here today I'm an idiot maybe
like you don't me to do more challenges
to live as suggesting of it in the
description and that's all for me for
now thanks for watching brownish yeah
that was too weird stay out stay awesome
I guess so [ __ ] hell it's ridiculous
how much I swear I like I want to swear
in every second ball play in this game
alright then the [ __ ] comes here and
he's like stop